[Musique]
eh bien regardez la deuxième partie du
piège de greg guillotin c'est très très
fort et là aujourd'hui va lui parler de
son projet il va mettre en place le
projet qui là pour julien courbet
regardez ces aidants au motif c'est
l'adrénaline que ça me procurer le
plaisir de consolider des carrières
fragile ouais parce que la mienne est
vraiment fragilité c'est des gens comme
toi qui vont m'aider à construire une
vraie carrière après 30 ans or
aujourd'hui le cul bordé noé aujourd'hui
tu es encore projecteurs ma solution
aujourd'hui julien courbet deuxième
partie il faut qu'on ne se salissent
donc on s'est demandé comment on va
salir courbes et en le rendant drôle
dans sans aucun doute été méchant la
mecque qu'à respecter un peu le code
pénal est bien là tu vas aller brûler je
vais aller contre la loi le titre du
programme un peu rock'n'roll auquel on a
pensé ses courbes et vous pisse à la
raie vous pissez l'arrêt tu me laisses
injuste s'appelait la mer ou juste pour
la prévenir qu'on veut quand elle veut
tomber tu as fait une petite subtilité
dans le pied qui veulent c'est l'arrêt l
apostrophe à 2 0t c'est là qu'il ya une
semaine
donc c'est l'arrêt de bus c'est là où tu
vas systématiquement les provoquer les
gens tomber dans une voiture on a un
mode planquer et on filme depuis la
quête situe à pisser sur les gens mais
verbalement par exemple via quelqu'un un
gros à un arrêt de bus
et toi tu sors bac s es tu vas face à
lui tu vises sa vague roularta bien
manger et cesser sinon j'étais tout à
fait égaux c'est le gros lot est bien
bouffer pour 3 aucune réaction
et là tu te barres en cours aux règles
et ugl joue pisse à la raie le taux que
la finalité c'est des insultes et aux
pauvres gros qui a rien de mambé les
affaires du clic à la salle du clic se
refaire
ce que je vais faire après c'est cris
qui met clegg très rapidement dirigés
après le gros je pense que j'ai un
procès et je me mets toutes les
personnes de forme aux taillades où j'ai
envie que les gens se disent prêts pour
baisser mon pote
du coup parce que j'ai dit à un type
très sympa parce que je suis venu le
voir par lui disant tout rares gros lard
je te pisse à la raie je me sens très
bien
elle a tous les jours vos propres
téléphones plus tard se courber mais
qu'il est sympa à hank rhon jeudi hong
kong et conquérante et les données
d'autres raisons que le noir le noir
tarifs vers le noir tu fais fait sombre
ici c'est déjà le bus de nuit ou quoi ce
qu'il faut en tout cas c'est que ce soit
jamais trop facile on n'est pas dans la
facilité de horn est justement dans le
petit truc qui fait on a vu ces
subtilités un petit truc j'ai jamais je
dirais ça jamais je vais lui dire une
personne forte taille dans le simple
fait d'imaginer que je veux dire c'est
vrai dans vie de 2,2 gerber et non
mérité son récit sa part par sa couleur
de peau leur époque et un complice parce
que tu as tu penses que j'assume je suis
peut-être un compteur avec des lunettes
est ce que tu veux mais je suis quand
même comprendre que l'ana la bonne elle
est dans le fait qu'il soit toujours je
montre le jingle jmj avez vous avez
vraiment faire remonter tout
[Musique]
tüv autorisés à filmer c'est bien voilà
la vie tu sais la famille sera vas-y
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le voilà ça commence dans une folie
j'imagine ça après le gros la salle à
manger
je te jure ce que fait confiance on
passe un cap dans sa carrière
le caire c'est sûr qu'au bon ben c'est
alors la mort d'amy chua notation doit y
aller vite
toi le problème je te dis c'est vraiment
l'histoire de propreté de ton image et
si je t'ai vu aujourd'hui en tout cas
c'est parce que tu en valait la peine
c'est tout ok ciao ciao
merci à toi ok pour tout les goûts c'est
plié de 2,8 engagé c'est ici mais tu
veux tu mets en train de dire pour
mettre le plus jamais je dirais s'érigea
de toi moi j'ai pas vu la paire de jeans
delebassé et ses bas ses maquettes à un
moment donné ça je vais le raconter sur
celle que l on expliqué que quand elle a
peut être sauvé un petit truc bien sûr
tout ça c'est fumer tue accueillir afin
de calculer j attends la sauce énervé ça
sert à rien puis je vous mets pas
m'énerver pour le dire et j'espère en
tout cas que tu me plais rising j'étais
parce que c'était surnaturel comme
abandonné et puis il était tellement
dans son truc
mois de septembre je serai sur scène je
le diffuserait pirelli sont assez libres
ont fait croire ça diffusant la vidéo
d'al sadd un combi la biblio moi je
démonte lemay et lorsqu'il est donc